ladies and gentlemen we have as always
saved the very best of the best for the
last to present the Award for Best
Picture one among us who has passed
beyond Fame to become legends happily in
his own time and ours winner himself of
two Academy Awards this man has a
personal strength and courage that
equaled his professional skill and his
daring and if it seems that I've made
this presenter of figure straight off
Mount Olympus I apologize for the
understatement ladies and gentlemen
Laurence Olivier
dear ladies and gentlemen thank you more
than I have ever wanted or tried to
thank anybody for such a perfectly
wonderful reception thank you so much I
hope I won't let the occasion done too
badly I'm here to present as the best
picture award and the winner for this is
Amadeus
thank you nine years ago Audrey Hepburn
gave us Oscars for Cuckoo's Nest
and tonight Sir Laurence Olivier for
Amadeus what a wonderful and rewarding
profession for a movie fan
the Gregory Peck and Larry Gelbart asked
me to speak for 55 minutes to make it a
four-hour show but I only have 32
minutes prepared there five pictures
nominated this year all had a curious
relationship in the fact that the
filmmakers who made them had to fight
and overcame many obstacles to make
their films and to film their visions
one has to be proud to be a peer of the
people who made killing fields Passage
to India soldier's story and places in
the heart
our thanks to Orion Pictures and
distributors and theater owners
throughout the world who recognized
Amadeus before it was released and and
thanks and thanks must be given to
others because regardless of what you
might have heard or what you might think
I really didn't do it all myself to
Neville Marriner Twyla Tharp and Joseph
Swoboda whose creative contributions to
Amadeus do not fit into any academy
category to a marvelous group of actors
whose talents no longer remain unsung
and to a Mike Houseman led crew composed
of Americans Englishmen Frenchmen
Italians Czechs and nine translators and
my love to my children John Athena Josh
Dorian to the boys from Myrtle and
Monroe and to the gang up in Berkeley
who were behind the picture all the way
thank you very much